bis prozent holt die spd bei der
bundestagswahl was glauben sie so viel
gab es mit starken grünen zusammen
reicht je weniger
[Musik]
meine damen und herren hier ist ihr
gastgeber los falle horst willkommen für
großen jubiläums ausgabe 150 jahre spd
halo 2
so drücken also ich stelle ihnen
vertragen zu 150 jahre spd besser
das kapital ist ein werk von karl markt
oder b auf dem konto von peer steinbrück
als kapitalist etwas wichtiges und wir
werden verfahrens an peer steinbrück
oder b
damit kleider verlorene man muss fragen
beantworten mensch ist doch ganz einfach
das spiel richtig sie sind jetzt live in
der krise wo die orte wo sie sehr nett
wenn sich umdrehen können was was
heimischer für die spd
scharping mit bar hopping ohne doping im
frühling pools oder die schafe in frage
da kann ich mich glaube ich nicht in
stress ist schwierig sind sie bereits
für die erste frage ehrlich ist das so
aber es ist schließlich ein bisschen
spannender macht also sind sie bereits
was ist am ende eines abends voller der
aschenbecher von helmut schmidt oder die
klaus wowereit macht lieber scholli im
gegensatz zur weit über und wenig gewinn
welche dieser worte passt nicht zum
namen der spd nah sozialdemokratische
partei deutschlands
seither steinbrück kanzlerkandidat der
spd ist die umfragewerte aber gesunken
oder b negativ gestiegen
die umfrageergebnisse sind nicht
nachträglich wir haben auch gut
beantwortet nicht die frage aber ich bin
politiker seit wann sind wir wären die
klar zu sagen die frage große waren
worten dass wir wahlen gewinnen
die schätzfrage wie viel prozent die spd
bei der bundestagswahl was glauben sie
so fiel der sieg mitfahren grünen
zusammen reicht je weniger erst einmal
richtig spannend
welchen blatt wird man von sigmar
gabriel nie hören ist ist bedanke mich
bei den wählern für diesen wahlerfolg
oder sp lehnte diese mascarpone creme
wieder mit ist du wirst immer wieder von
religiös blasius den wahlen in
niedersachsen und den schritt holstein
und dem nordrhein westfalen wer hier
richtig gewesen
und das war's auch schon wieder bei
sowie arno sowie und wie zu erwarten
bei der spd leider keine gewinner und
damit zurück ins studio